luke is with us in green bay hi luke
welcome to the dave ramsey show
thank you good afternoon dave and chris
sure uh question for you today is
regarding umbrella insurance my wife and
i
a few years ago got a one million dollar
umbrella policy liability and just
curious if there's a certain net worth
where we should look at adding to it on
the two and three and four million as
you go along or is there a certain ratio
that you can say you kind of have a rule
of thumb for
well it starts to get ridiculous when
you get above five million
the bargain is one million you a couple
hundred bucks you can buy one million
umbrella
but above five million you start to get
ridiculous um
i mean i have found a 10 million that's
decent i think i've got 10 right now
but i also have the dave ramsey problem
i mean if i bump into somebody they're
gonna be going oh i'm okay what's your
name dave ramsey oh god you know and so
all of a sudden you know it's like i got
a big target on my butt right so um
i went ahead and picked up an extra
level of it but i don't know that i
would necessarily recommend that
anything above 5 million what i do tell
you to do when you get above the million
need i mean if you're starting to sit on
a net worth of um
uh you know
north of three to five million dollars
and that kind of a thing you're starting
to worry a million dollars probably not
enough you really need to start looking
at other risk management things you can
do then and that's starting to put
assets into
uh llc's
and trusts and so forth i personally do
not own a single thing anymore i don't
even own my cars
my cars are in llc's and that's all from
a risk management standpoint that the
owner of the car is the only person that
could only only entity that could get
sued if something happened the
individual only way i could get sued
personally is if i had committed a
criminal act
and they could they could pierce it then
but but um so like one of my farms is in
one llc this building is in a trust
uh
and so on i don't personally own
anything and that way if someone falls
over in one of those properties or
something happens around one of those
items
they can only if you lost the lawsuit
they could only take the assets in that
entity
that's right and you bring up the
statement risk management which is huge
because you can work so hard to build
wealth but if you don't protect it the
right way with an umbrella policy which
all that is folks is it's another layer
of coverage over your automobile and
your homeowners and so it's just like an
umbrella that you'd walk outside with
it's that extra layer of protection and
dave said it a million dollar policies a
couple hundred dollars a year yeah and
so you can get that in place but the llc
and the trust they've are crucial things
for people to get set up well and what
you're gonna find is is that when you
get north of five million dollars in net
worth if you're being wise and watching
everything there's two things that get
that start three things you start to get
very complicated your taxes
your risk management
portfolio meaning you start buying
things in the name of something else
and uh
your estate plan
and the three of those things work
together you need to have the entities
built in such a way that they serve the
estate plan but also serve risk
management and so that that's where you
know you're going to start to spend some
money on defense yes and on diligence um
to keep the government's hands off to
keep a target off your butt that kind of
stuff but you know it's such a small
dollar very competitive very few times
do i would i suggest it would be highly
unusual for me to suggest more than a
five million dollar umbrella an umbrella
only covers liability too it doesn't
cover anything else so it's not it's not
covering the property itself you get
covered with traditional insurance yeah
but the umbrella it just attaches to the
liability limits on the top of your car
policy the top of your liability limits
on your car policy the top of the
liability limits on your homeowner's
policy extends them out another million
dollars and 250 bucks somewhere around
there and we've got all kinds of
everyday millionaires out there so if
this is something that rings true for
you i want you to go to daveramsey.com
and click on the insurance elp and start
to have that conversation like this is
the time to get those things in place